apenas unas horas después del inicio de
la invasión rusa de Ucrania la Unión
Europea golpeó a Moscú con sanciones
económicas y congeló los activos de
algunos de sus dirigentes
estas medidas incluyen sanciones
financieras que cortan el acceso de
Rusia a los mercados más importantes
Ahora nos dirigimos al 70% del sector
bancario ruso así como a las empresas
estatales incluidas las del sector de
defensa
las sanciones que entraron en vigor por
primera vez en 2014 tras la anexión de
crimea se intensificaron a medida que
continuaba la ofensiva la Unión Europea
cerró sus cielos y puertos a los barcos
y aviones rusos el bloque suspendió
entonces las emisiones de los canales de
medios estatales sputnik y RT el 27 de
febrero de 2022 los países del g7
congelaron activos del Banco Central
ruso por valor de 300 mil millones de
euros Poco después otros bancos rusos y
bielorrusos también fueron objeto de
sanciones y excluidos del sistema
financiero internacional Swift la Unión
Europea embargo activos de los oligarcas
sancionados y otras naciones
occidentales como Estados Unidos
siguieron rápidamente su ejemplo
hoy anunció que voy a Añadir decenas de
nombres de oligarcas a nuestras listas
incluidos los millonarios más ricos del
país y voy a prohibir que más de 50
oligarcas sus familias y sus asociados
viajen a Estados Unidos
mientras que Estados Unidos impuso desde
el principio una prohibición sobre el
petróleo y el gas rusos la Unión Europea
tardó en hacer lo mismo a principios de
abril del año pasado Bruselas prohibió
finalmente las importaciones rusas de
gas y carbón y el 5 de diciembre entró
en vigor el embargo petrolero del bloque
en vísperas de su aplicación los países
del g7 y pusieron un tope al precio del
petróleo ruso ahora en el aniversario
del inicio de la guerra la Unión Europea
ha puesto sus ojos en la industria de
defensa para su décimo paquete de
sanciones hasta la fecha las medidas ya
han afectado a más de 1.300 personas y
171 entidades